hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast bioburden and biofilm
control in the pharmaceutical industry
presented by dr. mark has more we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots to
learn more about lab roots pleases WWL
our roots calm I am junio Laura
collaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. mark has more dr. pasmore
currently manages the research center in
Australia T assurance department at
baxter healthcare his research includes
biofilm analyses rapid microbial methods
alternative sterilization techniques and
new product development he formerly has
healthy position of assistant research
professor at Montana State University
Department of Chemical Engineering in
his role at Montana State he was the
medical project supervisor at the Center
for biofilm engineering when he studied
biofilms in infection and medical
systems such as hemodialysis systems
additionally dr. pasmore work as a
senior engineer at steris corporation or
his research involved the evaluation and
development of sterilization and
decontamination technologies he has
multiple publications and presentations
in the field of biofilm research and
he's involved in several professional
and standards organizations related to
bacterial control and sterilization
including the PDA task force on
bioburden biofilm management please join
me in welcoming dr. pasmore I will now
turn the presentation over to him thank
you Judy I appreciate that introduction
so welcome everyone I am appreciate this
opportunity to talk to you about
bioburden and biofilm control in the
pharmaceutical industry without any
further ado we'll go ahead and get going
so Before we jump into it though I
wanted to show you a picture of a
beautiful biofilm before we start
talking about the ones that aren't so
friendly this is actually a hot spring
at Yellowstone National Park and the
colors that you see in that hot spring
the oranges the yellows the greens are
due to my own bacteria growing in that
environment all right so if nothing else
my goals for this presentation are to
get you to think about biofilms early
and if you're working in the area of
microbial control for planning for the
potential of biofilms about burton
contamination all right a little bit of
an outline / what we're going to be
talking about so I'm going to give you a
little bit more background on bioburden
and biofilms talking a little bit about
its implications to the pharmaceutical
industry and then we'll get into some of
those control ideas we'll talk about
design for control detection of
microorganisms remediation of
microorganisms the potential for
reoccurrence and therefore the need for
prevention and then with a little
summary all right so judy was kind
enough to mention my role in the PDA
task force we recently just published a
technical report on bioburden and
biofilm management and right here you
can see an outline of the sections in
that really good resource I really like
it and if you notice it actually kind of
mirrors my presentation today a few
sections on kind of background an
introduction then talking about design
detection and [ __ ]
in those two other topics a couple
things I stole from that so the first
one that it states early on is I'm going
to just going to go ahead and read this
it is important to educate engineers
scientists and managers about the
science of my burden and biofilms given
the broad and complex challenge of my
offered management to summarize that
what it really means to me is this is a
team effort these are complicated
challenges and we can't do it alone we
really need to work as an organization
whatever organization you're in to be
able to effectively tackle that so with
this you may be wondering what I mean by
a bio burn when I say that essentially
bioburden are viable microorganisms in
the manufacturing setting these can be
associated with personnel with the
environment with the equipment with
packaging with materials but most
critical these are things that could end
up in our finished products we really
want to make sure that we properly
control them so that we have safe
product all right so a little background
on biofilms so biofilms are made up of
multiple microorganisms their
communities these microbial communities
attach themselves to surface excuse me
surfaces and given time they'll produce
extra cellular materials that helps glue
themselves to the surface bacteria have
been around for approximately three
point six billion years and the fossil
record suggests that biofilms formed as
early as three billion years ago and I
mentioned this because it really
demonstrates that these organisms have
been allowed around adapting to their
environments for an extremely long
period of time so as you can imagine
they've adapted to quite a wide variety
of environments you can be found
virtually everywhere if you've been
sitting in on some of the earlier
biofilm talks you may have seen figures
similar this I'm just going to step
through it real quickly to talk about
really what happens in biofilm formation
it happens in a series of stages usually
there's an early attachment event or
free-floating microorganisms attached to
the surface they'll do some early
colonization and growth given enough
time you'll actually
continue to grow and oftentimes develop
much more complicated three-dimensional
structures and eventually you'll see
detachment events those are usually
sloughing or seating activities
sloughing meaning large chunks breaking
off and potentially floating away and
seating is actually a mechanism whereby
the organisms dissolve their own matrix
and floater swim in a way individually
so these are multi species communities
so as you probably are aware
microorganisms actually come in a wide
array of shapes sizes and behaviors and
that they once you can adapt to multiple
environments and in most of those
environments there are multi species
biofilms it's very uncommon to find
single species biofilms it does happen
in some extreme cases such as when we
put them under very harsh conditions as
we try to do we're trying to prevent
them in the manufacturing environment
but single species biofilms is the
exception not the rule and these
organisms will adapt over time if we put
pressures on them they will select for
the most tolerant organisms and you will
see those being the most prevalent over
time and so to summarize that
essentially the way I think of bio burn
in the manufacturing environment as many
ever moving targets so it's certainly a
challenge as we try to prevent these all
right so going a little bit more into
the pharmaceutical industry there's
quite a wide array of pharmaceuticals
that are made you are probably familiar
with a number of them there's all those
forms things topicals other different
medications and sterile injectables are
somewhere probably the most challenging
of those when it comes to a microbial
control standpoint so these are
manufactured in a number of different
ways they could be a non sterile
manufacturing terminally sterilized
where we sterilize the product after it
has been made an aseptic processing
where they're essentially initially
sterilized and brought together usually
with a final filtration immediately
militant excuse me immediately
prior to fill in the solution so the
need for microbial and by Oberon control
around me is very significantly you can
imagine an oral dose form that's going
to go into an environment that already
has a lot of microorganisms associated
with it the mouth and the intestinal
tract a few non pathogenic organisms
introduced in that environment are
certainly not going to be the danger or
safety risk that injecting those into
the bloodstream would be so as such the
microbial and bioburden control that we
have to do vary significantly the most
significant of that is the aseptic
processing where we need to produce
sterile product without having the tool
to do some type of terminal
sterilization so what sterile basically
means is that it's free from viable
microorganisms and then it has an
acceptable limit of pyrogens which will
kind of touch on as we go through and
this is becoming an ever-increasing
challenge for the medical and
pharmaceutical industries so the young
gentleman in the picture here his name
is alex alex is a type 1 diabetic and as
such he needs to take insulin multiple
times a day and with diabetes as he
continues to grow older he is going to
have some challenges around his immune
system and so need to continue to take
medication and that medication has to be
free of microorganism so he can safely
take it without having risks of
receiving an infection and once again
this is an increasing population with
things like oncology and autoimmune
diseases other diseases that have left a
increasing portion of our population
susceptible to infection all right
before we go into some of the control
measures I wanted to talk a little bit
about some of the myths that are out
there around bioburden and biofilm
control the first one of those being
that if you have had some good numbers
on your detection methods you're doing
your microbial monitoring and you
not seen hi bioburden counts for a while
you're in a good point that's not always
true so basically yes if you've had a
good count that's certainly not a bad
thing however when we think about it
especially in the case of biofilms where
you can have surface associated
microorganisms that only cedar shut
occasionally you might go an extended
period of time without any issues then
have a seating or sloughing event and
have your number Spica above the
acceptance limits so just because you
have recently had some good numbers does
not necessarily mean you're in a state
of control alright the next one is that
high flow rates can control biofilms and
that's also not necessarily true at the
bottom is a figure demonstrating
essentially flow in a pipe so the errors
rex Cuse me be heroes represent flow
rates the large arrows being high flow
rates in the small arrows being low flow
rates and like most piping what you see
is the highest flow rates in the middle
of the pipe and as you approach the
walls those flow rates reduce
significantly such that actually within
depending on the flow rate tens to
hundreds of microns from the surface you
actually get into what's considered a
viscous sub layer or a boundary layer
where the flow drops to near zero and
there is virtually no share on that
surface and you can imagine with
microorganisms being 12 microns in size
typically that attend to a potentially
100 micron area where they can grow
without stress is certainly plenty of
room for biofilm to develop alright the
next one is around dead legs and the
lack of flow being the problem with
those now certainly flow is a good thing
from minimizing potential growth in
these areas but in the last comment I
made that you know flow can't prevent
biofilms therefore it also on the flip
side won't be your problem blaka flow
won't be your problem with these dead
legs it's really the problem is they
don't typically get cleaned out they
don't see the same removal and treatment
regimes that the rest of the
manufacturing would
and lastly here is that you can't
remediated biofilm that's not to save my
own phones aren't extremely difficult to
remediate it can certainly pose a
significant challenge however they in
most cases can be remediated what I tend
to see is that a lot of times when they
can't be remediated because either the
source of the biofilm or sources of the
biofilm can't be identified or there is
potentially a design flaw on a
particular piece of equipment so those
type of issues may make it very
difficult to remediate a biofilm you
might have to change out equipment or
continuing investigation to identify
where the problem really is alright
before we jump into the pharmaceutical
industry I want to talk about a couple
other industries just for comparison so
the semiconductor industry actually uses
a lot more water than the pharmaceutical
industry there a particular company can
use as much as a million gallons a day
of water and that water needs to be very
free of microorganisms microorganisms
represent particulate that can affect
their silicon wafer production and
therefore they do a very thorough job of
controlling in fact their controls are
usually about 10 times more rigorous
than what you would see in the
pharmaceutical industry or another way
to say that is their acceptance levels
are about a tenth of what you would see
in the pharmaceutical industry so a lot
of water and even with of that high
level of control you will occasionally
see some type of colonization in their
systems and of course there's a lot of
expense involved the picture at the
bottom there is actually a
representation of a water system in the
semi con a silicon wafer industry and a
lot of expense associated with doing our
controlling waters of that level on the
flip side is the food and beverage
industry where you can imagine there's a
lot of nutrients present the nutrients
for us usually make great nutrient
sources for microorganisms as well so
cleaning and disinfection become very
critical and of course the food and end
it food and beverage industry do this
very well on a daily basis so it is
possible to clean these and sometimes
clearly challenging métier
girls to clean you know examples such as
peanut butter which getting enough of a
surface has certainly got to be some
work for that industry is certainly
doable and one of the ways that we'll
talk a little bit more about is not only
having good cleaning disinfection but
also making sure their systems are as
dry as possible so worrying about things
like drain ability not using water when
they don't need two things along those
lines so something to keep in mind as
we're walking through the other slides
all right now coming to the
pharmaceutical industry like starting
with interesting pictures I really liked
this one this one is actually from
reverse osmosis membrane what the larger
structures that you see in it are
actually the spacers between the
membranes so this is a course on
microscope microscopic view blown up and
what you can see is actually a biofilm
growing kind of right out in space
clinging to multiple of these spacer
fibers so a lot of times we think about
biofilms as being surface associated but
sometimes they can be very much three
dimensionally into your fluid path okay
so I'm gonna be talking about some of
the challenges and there's really four
that I'm going to be discussing the
first one is the prevalence of
microorganisms in the environment and
the potential challenges that creates
despite being an engineer I'm not going
to be using any equations the closest
thing I have to one is right here and
it's basically if you have bacteria and
water and you give it enough time you're
really going to have a biofilm form now
what that time is is going to vary
significantly with your system which
microorganisms our presence in the
nutrients available all right arm so
kind of going into that ubiquitous
nature microorganisms are everywhere
they can enter your system so you will
need to worry about any grass and once
they're there they can proliferate and
so when I think of microbial control one
of the parallels I like to draw is a
comparison with fire safety I think it's
because pretty much all of us in school
or in our professional careers have had
some type of training
fire safety which you know if you
remember back to that there's really
three elements they tell you to control
there's your fuel source there's your
oxygen and there's your ignition source
and similarly it's true with bioburden
control you've got your nutrients your
fuel source you've got your water which
could parallel pretty fairly with you
know the oxygen for fire and your
microorganism to your ignition source
that if you can control any of those
effectively you have a good chance of
controlling your bio burn those are all
very challenging to control so on
there's a lot of work that goes into
that so we talk about ingress it's
things such as leaks human contact
cross-contamination we talk about water
you know controlling it through means of
course minimizing but that's often not
possible in a lot of systems where you
need water to make your solutions then
you need to worry about drain ability
pooling of that water how long that
water sits around and we're possible if
you can create harsh environments during
your manufacturing then you can minimize
the potential for proliferation the food
industry uses us regularly they call it
hurdle technology putting as many
obstacles in the way of the
microorganisms as possible alright so a
little bit more on the contamination
sources in the pharmaceutical industry
touch contamination is probably our
biggest source humans have a significant
amount of bacteria associated with them
the estimates are that there's ten
bacterial cells enter on the human body
for every human cell so there's
certainly a potential for contamination
there and a lot of those organisms are
already growing in a surface associated
or biofilm mode of growth so it's not
too hard for them to switch into that
once they're in the manufacturing system
as well other sources include raw
materials water that's being used air
which we are certainly designed for but
sometimes I think it's overlooked on the
day-to-day operations within
manufacturing and then leaks and cross
contamination so I actually don't mind
so much the leaks that we can see
because we can
pick those up and we can fix those what
really concerns me is when we have leaks
that we can't see for example heat
exchangers have the potential for having
holes between the clean and dirty side
and one that happens you have the
potential for microorganisms crossing
over and connect contaminating your
product alright getting a little bit
more into design control and prevention
so when you're designing systems really
it is about safety and quality which to
me the best way to do that is starting
with a risk assessment basically looking
at your system going through it in
detail and understanding the microbial
risks that are involved those risks can
be used in your designing and that
should include facility design equipment
design water systems as well as your
process design so looking at the
potential for ingress due to those
sources we mentioned personnel raw
materials etc also your proliferation
times these are time such as when you're
performing your manufacturing how long
are you going to let your solution or
your other materials sit while you're
waiting to fill or moving on to the next
step if these are not bacterial static
or bacterial sitel there's potential for
proliferation and so you have to worry
about how much time we're going to sit
there growing in addition to that once
you're finished with whatever process it
is how long are the system's going to be
allowed to sit there before they're
cleaned and sanitized and once you've
cleaned and sanitized them how long are
they going to be allowed to hold until
you start your next manufacturing
operation all of those times have the
potential to allow for microbial growth
and therefore potential for risk further
for your next operation and there's
there is persistence and we're excuse me
persistence prevention what I mean by
that is you can have microorganisms
getting in you can have them growing but
you can also have them surviving your
treatment so working on preventing any
risks that you have around around those
excuse me surviving that cleaning and
sanitization
so that then can all be built into a
cleaning disinfection and sterilization
program and then that should be trended
and we'll talk more about trending in a
little bit all right equipment design
one of the parts I actually really enjoy
it starts with materials of construction
whatever you're making your equipment
out of is it cleanable is a compatible
what are your connections are they
welded are they seals hopefully there's
no threads threads can create a
significant problem for growth in these
areas filtration is certainly a useful
component however filtration only is
effective at preventing issues upstream
of the filter anything after the filter
can't be controlled by that filter so
it's usually good to place it really
close to your next unit operation you
need to think about your moving parts
valves and pumps things like that can
break down over time and create areas
for microbial proliferation and
retention also part washers and troughs
so in many systems not all of the
components can be cleaned in place they
need to be taken off of the system and
cleaned out of place so those are those
pumps and washers or whatever I'm
seasoning the different components that
need to be cleaning can be taken to the
trough and clean there because they're
going to be cleaned in these systems
those systems need to be maintained in a
very similar level to your manufacturing
system if they're not there's a
potential for microbial proliferation in
your washers and trough and then rather
than cleaning your parts you could be
actually contaminating them in these
systems so we already talked a little
bit about dead legs those are certainly
important drops really you want to get
rid of all of those that you can if you
have to have drops which sometimes you
do because you have components that
going to be connected and disconnected
they seem to need to see the same
treatment regime as the rest of your
system you need to make sure also that
your systems are sloped and drainable
and see pro excuse me have proper
surface finishes if you're interested in
finding out more about this the American
Society mechanical engineering has a
great standard the bio processing
engineering
standard which really goes into a lot of
depth on on all these different
components and I highly recommend it for
anyone who's working in this area
alright so moving on to the next one
this is going to be our first poll so I
would ask the moderator to please load
the pole and for those of you hopefully
you're able to see the pole and what I'm
going to ask is that you look at the
diagram there there is an aseptic excuse
me an asymmetric connector and that asa
net symmetric connector can be connected
connected in a couple different
configurations your configuration a
configuration be and I'm going to ask
you to choose which of those
configurations is better for microbial
control standpoint so take a second take
a look and let me know which one you
think is better alright hopefully
everyone is putting in their answers and
if we could hopefully it's enough time
for everyone if we could go ahead and
wrap it wrap up the pole alright the
poll has closed and we have sixty-three
percent that say a and 36 that say be so
looks like the answer that's preferred
is a a is actually a pretty good design
if you're looking from left to right or
if you're looking at it with flow going
from left to right and you're trying to
drain this configuration you can see
that you can actually drain it without
hold up whereas with Abby if you're
trying to drain that you can see that
there might be holed up which might
create a potential risk for
microorganisms I have to tell you
actually this was a trick question both
answers are equally correct or wrong
depending on what you're actually
considering with the system because a
although it's really great for draining
if you're looking also from left to
right with flow you could have in a
scenario where you're trying to clean it
you have air and trapped in that
cleaning solution you could actually
have air bubbles coming out of solution
and collecting at the top part of of
that ledge there in a potentially
creating an area where you're not
getting your cleaning solution exposed
to that entire surface so I know this is
a trick question but it is really to get
you thinking about that there is
sometimes more than one issue that's
involved with this design now if we were
reversing the flow if the flow is
actually going from right to left then B
is actually a really good design for
that type of flow scenario because your
drain ability is good and also your
clean ability is good but we out can't
always go from a small diameter to a
large diameter so it really depends on
your system alright so this is the
second question this one really I'm just
going to ask you use the question in
answer box we're not going to actually
do this as a poll this is an image of a
water processing system it's actually
not a pharmaceutical manufacturing
system however it has some issues with
it some that are mean when concerned
about just from a water handling
standpoint but definitely ones that I'm
worried about if this were used for
manufacturing the pharmaceutical
environment so take a minute go ahead
and use your question and answer tool
and let me know if you see any issues
that are occurring there
alright so hopefully we're getting some
of those in I don't oh here we go I
think they're coming up alright so
threat IC threaded pipe concerns
concerns with threads and ball valves
potential dead legs so good good you're
seeing most of what's in there it's
great to hear that some folks are able
to pick those up there's a number of
things that you've already picked up on
a lot of those potential our threaded
connections potential dead legs ball
valves there's also what you might see
in here in addition to the threads
there's leaks there's actually dripping
taking place so yes there there's a lot
of things going on here that you really
want to fix if you're concerned about
your bioburden control alright so moving
on then to inspection and maintenance
inspection and maintenance are really
critical as well so some of that has to
do with the fact that equipment just
fails over time that given enough time
virtually everything is going to fail
and so you need to keep an eye on what's
happening with with equipment over time
there's the potential for corrosion
hitting cracking leaking other things
that can potentially create areas where
biofilms or other microorganisms can set
up and survive through not only during
manufacturing but during the treatment
subsequent to manufacturing so during
inspection making sure that those items
are noted and addressed is important the
other thing that I've seen done with
manufacturing maintenance is also using
it for microbial inspection there was a
great presenter from J&J who did some
talking about using it in microbial
control strategy that regularly these
systems are opened up and when they're
opened up it's an opportunity to see
what's going on in there there is always
the chance and I fully expect this is
happening unfortunately across many
industries where you have a repair
person that is opening up a piece of
equipment let's say a pump for
maintenance and they see a slime
that's growing in there but they don't
really think twice about it because
they're there to fix whatever problem is
they fix the problem and they put that
pump right back into use well of course
they're putting that microbial
contamination right back into the system
so this is an opportunity as i see it to
basically use this for microbial control
either educating those maintenance folks
about you know the potential risks if
they see something going on
discoloration growth in there or
potentially having one of your microbial
control folks walk the lines with them
when they're doing their periodic
inspections or maintenance when they're
opening up the system have somebody who
knows about microbial control working
with them educating them and checking
out the different components as they're
being opened up all right so this is I
guess is a little bit of a summary of
what we've been talking about under
these parts of the control so you start
when you're talking about
pharmaceuticals you start with your
target product profiles and then you
look at your material controls looking
at your contamination sources your
operators you look at your proliferation
times your early colonization you try to
eradicate that before becomes a problem
in and really this should be all race
based on your risk assessment okay so
that moves us on to the next challenge
around bioburden and biofilms which is
the difficulty of detecting all right so
when you're thinking about detection of
microorganisms in a manufacturing
setting the first thing you need to
think about is where you going to do
your sampling hopefully this is based
around your microbial control plan
you're going to be thinking about okay
what kind of sample am I taking
typically we take a liquid sample there
are occasions where we might take a
surface sample usually a swab do we pick
the right location if we are taking a
surface sample how accessible is the
location would like to get to we might
be swabbing the tank but the real issue
might be in a valve upstream biofilms
are very heterogeneous they don't
necessarily occur consistently across
your system once we have that sample
then we've got to take it to some type
of an al
typically that's an auger plate although
there are some manufacturers some
vendors out there that are coming up
with very interesting new ways to detect
microorganisms but sticking with our our
old standby the agar plate how
culturable are those microorganisms on
the selection of auger so there's always
a question there about you know are we
being able to detect them due to the
choices that we make there and even if
they do grow what is a colony forming
unit mean if you have nice broken up
individual cells you should hopefully
get one colony for every microorganisms
you started with a larper if you've got
biofilm detachment you might have a
chunk of 10,000 microorganisms that only
grow up into one colony so there's
question about how effectively you can
numerate in some of those scenarios all
right microbial detection for me is
really more than just detection it's
really about microbial monitoring as I
mentioned it really needs to align with
the risk assessment what are the
critical control points where are the
highest risks and are you monitoring in
those areas what are your plans for you
know what's your sampling per batch if
you have an intervention which what's
your plan for sampling around that
intervention or maintenance and
inspection after you put the system back
together do you do some sampling to make
sure that there was nothing introduced
as far as contamination during that
maintenance and then trending to me this
is one of the most important parts
because as I mentioned before a single
point only gives you a snapshot it
doesn't really tell you if you're in
control so understanding those counts
over time and I Dean making sure you
understand what type of microorganisms
are involved over time all right so that
moves us to the next of our challenges
which is decontamination and so if you
have ideal design control and prevention
hopefully you never get to a point where
you need to remediate your system
because if you have to remediate
especially if you have to remediate a
biofilm it's very challenging in some
cases depending on what you're using to
sanitize a biofilm you might have to use
tooth out as much as two
thousand times the concentration of what
a preventive treatment is so it's kind
of funny I jumped straight to
remediation and kind of skipped over
that prevention piece at first but the
reason I did that is because really you
want to be on the preventive side you
want to be proactive not reactive when
it comes to microbial control because if
you have to be reactive you're behind
the eight-ball you really are going to
be challenged to get that removed and
dealt with so ways to prevent that we
already talked a little bit about making
sure that you have microbial barriers
minimizing your interests of
microorganisms into the system you also
want to as we talked about minimize
proliferation of microorganisms in the
system you want to come up with good
preventive cleaning and sanitization
program and then I've got antifouling on
here now when I say anti following I'm
not really thrilled with some of the
antifouling materials that are out there
in the manufacturing environment or that
are being sold into the manufacturing
environment but what I'm talking about
here is just making sure that you have
the proper surface finishes things along
those lines to minimize potential for
bacterial attachment and growth so those
could include not only your surface
finish but things like are your welds
polished you don't want to create
attachment point to be a doodle welds or
other issues such as that of course we
can't always prevent bioburden and bio
films from growing in the system
occasionally we do have an issue we need
to be able to remediate that and the
very best way to remediate biofilm
especially is replacement of your parts
so that's not a very popular one
especially if you have potentially
millions of dollars invested in your
manufacturing environment you don't want
to scrap millions of dollars of
equipment to do your prevention however
it's extremely effective but where I'm
talking realistically about here is what
about your disposable should probably
not gonna throw away a
hundred-thousand-dollar tank or a
two-hundred-thousand-dollar piece of
equipment but what about your
replaceable gaskets your rubber gaskets
those are notorious places for microbial
growth you should be looking at those
you know a five dollar gasket to save
you thousands of dollars
potentially in lost product is certainly
worth discarding that and starting out
with the starting over with a fresh one
so looking at those um you know gaskets
your seals your other wearable
components that you might want to
replace now one of the next best ways to
treat is mechanically removal so if you
can scrub away those biofilms that's
certainly a great way to remove them not
I was feasible within your manufacturing
system so what most folks rely on was
Lucas companies look to is bacterial
sidle treatments where you're going to
chemically kill the biofilm and then
lastly on here I've got cleaning which
is probably not quite as effective and
as chemical treatment but certainly
beneficial and although I've got it last
on the order because it's maybe not as
effective as the bacterial sidle most of
these you're not going to use solely
just in and of themselves so usually
you're going to use cleaning in
combination with some type of bacterial
sidle treatment to really give you a
much more rigorous cleaning and if
you're able to you mechanical on
combination with those you might use all
three of those last three with replacing
of your disposable parts to really get
yourself to a place where you're in
control again all right um excuse me
when it comes to cleaning and
sanitization it is not a one size fits
all I talked a little bit about the
silicon wafer industry in the food
industry you can imagine that you can't
design one cleaning regime that would be
effective for both of those scenarios
similarly it's true in the
pharmaceutical environment depending on
what pharmaceuticals are being made you
need to tailor the cleaning and
sanitization to that system typically
and involve some type of rinsing
followed by some type of cleaning
followed by sanitization hot water and
steam are used very commonly in the
pharmaceutical industry sometimes
chemical sanitizers can work when it
comes to chemicals you need to think
about your concentration your contact
time your pH or temperature and is it
compatible with your surfaces and I've
got the next one underlined here because
to me this one is critical and
occasionally overlooked
whether your sanitizing the heat or be a
cat via chemical treatment you need to
make sure that your treatment is
effective over the length of treatment
and when I say that that would mean for
example if your hot water is entering a
system at 80 °c for sanitization but
over the process of your whole system
it's cooling down such that when it
comes out it's at room temperature
there's probably a significant portion
of your system that's not receiving any
treatment so it needs to go through the
needs to be at an effective temperature
or its chemistry concentration
throughout that entire link and over the
entire time frame so if you've got a 30
minute min treatment it needs to be
effective over that entire time frame
alright um and then I highly recommend
that you have some type of remediation
back-up plan in place prior to having a
problem because if you are shut down
because your system is contaminated it's
not a very fun spot to be and you want
to have that alternative treatment in
your back pocket you could potentially
use the same treatment as what you do
currently but usually you have more
tolerant organisms that have potentially
survived it in the past and what it's
going to take to make that effective it
is going to be challenging so you're
probably better off having some type of
alternative just in case i personally
prefer some of the oxidative sanitizers
but there are certainly a number of
things out there that can be used all
right we're to our third and last
question for you so this one is around
and I I don't know if this poll is
actually available I'm good okay here it
is so the question is is how do you know
that your sanitization regime is
effective in manufacturing so um how
there's some options here you know you
can be looking at your periodic trending
ah you could be looking at your your
designer doing in the design of
experiments potentially validating it
and then of course there's always tried
and true cross your fingers and help so
if you could take a look at those and
give me some answers
give everyone just a little bit of time
here to pick their answer there all
right hopefully everyone's finishing up
we can probably go ahead and give them
just a maybe 10 more seconds and close
the poll okay all right great poll is
closed and it looks like the biggest
choice with forty four percent is
validated followed by periodic trending
of the flora and then the design of
experiments and so what we currently do
the traditional way to do it is we
validate it now that means we basically
try the chemistry in there in a study in
the system and we see how it works let
me ask you in the manufacturing and
environment and this is not a poll this
is just for you to think about does that
tell you the effectiveness for treating
bioburden and I'm sorry to say in some
cases it doesn't because in the
manufacturing environment one of the
things we can't do is we can't introduce
a challenge we can't put microorganisms
into that environment nobody wants us to
introduce bacteria and something that
we're about to make their
pharmaceuticals and so it's not a
sometimes a very rigorous challenge the
validation process but it is the way
that we currently do it and if it's a
problem for bioburden in general what do
you think it tells us about the
effectiveness of biofilm treatment we're
not even looking at the the surfaces
typically we're just looking at what's
happening in solution so you can imagine
there's some holes there so those of you
who put validation had the correct
answer as it is today that said those of
you who put microbial monitoring and
kind of periodic review that's my
preference for really being able over
long-term to truly tell if you're in a
state of control it's really that long
term trending that gives you a better
idea i think as to whether your overall
control so both of those answers are
correct answers obviously that the
validations what's currently being done
hopefully the
companies that are doing this are doing
really good jobs with their training so
that they can stay on top of that
control and then design of experiments
one way to actually get a little bit
better idea of how effectively your
chemistry's or your heat or things like
that are is you could do a benchtop
study you're going to have to do some
type of minimal studies to make sure
things are effective I personally like
having some type of bench top studies
there are some ASTM standards out there
for testing some of these treatments if
you're interested those are listed here
excuse me on one example that we've done
it Baxter is actually growing up a
biofilm this work was done in
cooperation with the Center for biofilm
engineering where we took stainless
steel surfaces grew biofilms on them
treated them with chlorine and looked at
what happened and what you can see the
picture on the left the the green image
is the untreated and the picture on the
right with with more red in it as the
treated after the preparations they were
treated with live dead stain which
essentially treats live organisms or
stains them as green dead organisms is
red you can see there is a significant
log reduction and to me just as
importantly as you can see a significant
removal as well which actually brings us
into the next theme which is the
potential for biofilms being a
reoccurring problem so biofilms if not
effectively killed can actually regrow
quite rapidly so if you only have a
partially effective kill you've
essentially left a lot of microorganisms
already sitting in your system waiting
for the next favorable environment to
grow back and even if you do kill them
but you don't remove them there's some
risk there was a study done that was by
the naval labs that looked at the time
for biofilm at least in one particular
environment to reform after it had been
killed so they took a surface a clean
surface the grill biofilm on it they
timed how long it took for that to grow
they inactivated the micro organ
is involved but didn't remove them put
some more microorganisms and looked at
the time for the biofilm to re-establish
and in their study they showed a roughly
one-tenth the time to reestablish the
biofilm as it as it took to originally
grow it so certainly removal is a
significant risk and it not only is it a
risk for regrowth of course typically
these are microorganisms that are
sitting around and they have the
potential even dead to put some
different endotoxins and other pyrogenic
compounds into your product so it's also
a risk from the patient standpoint as
far as pyrogens alright so going on to
biofilm remediation I basically my
suggestion is I've talked before is be
prepared really have a back-up plan in
place do a good investigation you walk
through your systems open it up if you
need to take a look inside and look at
your high risk areas when possible
replace disposable components definitely
replace anything that's now functioning
or has issues then after that you're
probably going to need to come in with a
multi iteration cleaning sanitization
process where you're going to cycle
cleaner sanitizer a few times and then
you're going to need to make sure when
you do it you're going to be at elevated
concentrations and elevated contact
times that's really what it usually
takes to be effective so that's that's
kind of the treatment measures after
you've done that I would highly
recommend that you do some LMA elevated
sampling for a while to really make sure
you return to a state of control and I
kind of like this biofilm picture so
stand by our micro scope group here at
Baxter and it looks like something's
crawling out of this biofilm so kind of
like it from the remediation standpoint
alright so moving on to the summary
around what we've been talking about
water is one of the main problems
microorganisms do many of the
microorganisms that are of issue are
going to be growing in water that's we
have challenges detecting these so
making sure you have a good
strategy for microbial detection there's
always the potential that can reoccur so
really making sure you have a proactive
strategy so continuing down that that
summary really for the pharmaceutical
industry it's thinking about what your
products are designing effectively for
those so that's equipment design your
control strategy so your processes
hopefully all based around a risk
assessment then I highly recommend good
maintenance programs and using that
maintenance program to do microbial
inspections as well really looking at
your long term monitoring and trending
for your bio burden and then if you do
detect an issue being ready to rapidly
treat that all right so with that I've
given you a few references throughout
the talk here's those summarized again I
believe there's going to be a PDF
available so these are some things that
I highly recommend that you have on hand
if you're looking to do some bioburden
controls the first two especially the
later ones if you want to do testing
around it and with that I'd like to
thank some of the individuals and
organizations that provided some of the
images you saw today in the presentation
also this image you may notice the name
on the back of the jersey of number 11
there it was the same name as on the
title slide so this gentleman is
actually that's a well-dressed redheaded
young gentleman Alex that we saw from
one of the previous slides alex is doing
well with his diabetes that the fact
that there are good microbial control
programs in place for the medicines he
used is obviously very important than
and I want to take this opportunity to
thank all of you that work in the
microbial control area for the safety
that you provide to your customers and
patients and with that I'd like to thank
everyone for your attendance and I will
be open it up to questions
thank you dr. pasmore for that
informative presentation so it's time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. pasmore please do so now
just click on the green do na button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question in the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for let's
get started our first question it is
lately I have seen the use of heat to
disinfect water systems also steam how
effective is heat alone to prevent or
remediate biofilm interesting question
and I'm going to hit it sorry I don't
know if you heard that first part of
that um the interesting question I'm
going to hit it at a very high level we
actually there's a colleague of mine who
is currently putting together a
publication on that and I don't want to
steal her thunder but what I will say is
that it can be very effective if you
provide the proper temperature in time
so 80 degrees C certainly has the
potential to inactivate at least the
biofilms that we have looked at if you
give it the appropriate time and that
you make sure that all of the areas that
have the potential for biofilm growth
are exposed and when I say all of the
areas you can imagine if you have
biofilms growing down into you know
connection points like gaskets alongside
of those are you really achieving the
full temperature throughout the entire
component isn't that entire biofilm
seeing that temperature if there are no
more questions I would like to once
again thank dr. pasmore for his
presentation oh wait I spoke too soon
okay um when chlorine based
disinfectants are used well stainless
steel pipes get eroded over time
it's another topic that I've certainly
heard a lot about very interesting and
it's one of the ones where I wish I had
an easy answer so let me hit some of the
topics around that chlorine can
potentially damage stainless steel it
certainly can be an issue there's a lot
of properties around that that really
impact how damaging it is to two
stainless steel so the chlorine
concentration it certainly has impact as
well as the ph acid acidic ph s can be
much more destructive to the stainless
steel then then sometimes even chlorine
itself but certainly chlorine at excuse
me low pH high acid concentration can be
challenging and then temperature hot
chlorinated compounds can be much more
damaging to the stainless steel than
what they would be at room temperature
so there's a lot of different things
that factor into you know how damaging
that chlorine can be to the stainless
steel I think that maybe hits a high
level there was a sorry the last thing
around that is how well you do your
rinses i have seen really good control
and minimal impact of stainless steel or
metals in general over time if that
chlorine can be effectively rinsed out
between treatments that typically your
chlorine treatments aren't very long but
we really can be damaging is if that
chlorine is allowed to sit on your
surfaces overnight or over multiple days
that's where I've seen the largest
amount of damage
okay so next we had a biofilm
contamination in our purified water
system we were told to sanitize monthly
using household bleach to prevent future
contamination is bleach effective to get
rid of and prevent biofilm contamination
okay um this is another one that it's
not a simple answer I've seen some some
very good work where bleach has been
used on biofilms and if you ever look at
the Center for biofilm Engineering's
website they actually have a video of
bleach remediation of a biofilm and they
do show significant inactivation and
removal over time this was about 50 ppm
or free chlorine and it was done over an
hour even after an hour though they
didn't completely remove or completely
inactivate the biofilm you see a very
significant reduction very significant
removal but that was really going to be
dependent on your concentration and your
contact time so once again it can be
used depending on how challenging your
biofilm is that may not be enough in and
of itself especially you really do want
to use it though in combination with
cleaning as well because bleach is going
to be reactive and if there are other
organic sitting around you might also
not get it effectively to that surface
so multi components to that question my
recommendations make sure it's really
clean so that you minimize the other
contaminants that are around try to get
it to concentrations the higher if
you're doing biofilm anything under 500
ppm would make me concerned and you want
to give it some extended contact time
depending on what you can allow for I
we've done some cases where even at that
concentration so we'll head it for an
hour hours if we're concerned with an
actual biofilm being present
do you recommend cleaning regimens as
well as disinfecting what is used
and I'm sorry GDA don't I think you got
cut off in the middle of that and I'm
not sure which one you were asking about
okay just give that a minute all right
you're asked do you recommend cleaning
regimens as well as disinfecting what is
used so yes I would certainly recommend
cleaning regiments as well as
disinfecting it's going to vary from
organization to organization we
typically at Baxter use various cleaning
regiments depending on which
pharmaceuticals we're making and then we
always follow it up with the
sanitization those do vary once again
depending on what chemistry's are
involved that you're trying to remediate
and then what your microbial load is
there is the potential there there are
certainly some chemistry's out there
that will both clean and sanitize
depending on what you're dealing with
you may be able to use one solution or
one chemistry to do at all if extra we
typically like a cleaner follow because
I mentioned with heat so using the
chemistry to do the removal and the heat
to do any inactivation of anything that
might be remaining when you recommend
other disinfectants besides CIP 100 and
200 for the CIP systems you know this is
an interesting question there are a
number of chemistry's out there some
very interesting ones I'm not at a
position at this point to probably make
some good recommendations on that we're
actually looking at a few of the other
alternatives currently in Baxter and I
don't have any data that I can report
out on that if things go well will
hope to be able to publish on that so
maybe next year we'll be able to talk
more freely about that at the moment
there isn't really any good
recommendations that I could make them
additional chemistry so I apologize for
that a couple Martha could you please
give a list of proving disinfectants for
cleaning the water systems okay so I
heard part of that the question is could
you please give a list of proven
disinfectants for cleaning the water
systems I think this this comes down
fairly similar probably to the last
question let me hit some of the high
levels of that basically i personally
prefer the oxidative disinfectants so
those include things like chlorine ozone
hydrogen peroxide peracetic acid a lot
of those chemistry is give biocidal
activity as well as removal which makes
them fairly effective against a lot of
the biofilms and other issues there are
some detergents that certainly can help
or with both cleaning and removal
depending on what your chemistry is you
may need to remove that as well sodium
hydroxide works for a lot of the
proteins and lipids so um I will step
back and say that it depends a little on
your system since you're talking water
systems there are a lot of literature
and information out there on course
ozone and hydrogen peroxide pure acetic
acid either by them hydrogen peroxide by
itself or in combination with peracetic
acid are all potentials you need to look
take a little bit of look at what your
materials are in your water system are
they compatible with those chemistry's
and I'm thinking hates another way to
inactivate it doesn't do as good a job
cleaning though so you may have to
combine that with a cleaner depending on
on your system and I'm sorry I know I'm
being a little bit general but it
as I mentioned earlier some of these
need to be tailored for the system have
so it would take a little bit of a
review of the water system to be able to
actually completely understand okay we
have time for one last question what
high temperature would you recommend so
um this is one that that also has some
variability in it and you know i hate
the depends answer but it does like so
many of these things among microbial
control on what what you're dealing with
and so let me start with if you have any
concerns with spores in your system you
need to be at steam temperatures
typically that's not an issue and most
of the systems we're talking about in
which case you can use a hot water
temperature a degree C is very common
across the industry it's nice and that
it's it's certainly proven to be
effective in a lot of different
scenarios you get some some rinsing with
it as well and most of the regulators
are pretty comfortable with that
temperature that said depending on once
again what you're manufacturing and what
the final form of it is the food
industry does most of their
pasteurization in the 55 to 65 degree
range so certainly for a number of
microorganisms you can go much cooler
than 80 degrees C so you know I know I'm
giving you just a few bits and pieces
there but without knowing your system I
can't give you an exact number I would
certainly say nothing but well 55
typically in the pharmaceutical industry
I wouldn't even want to do 65 but there
is some literature that suggests maybe
you don't have to go to 80 degrees C for
effective in activation of these
microorganisms that said depending on
what your your biggest concerns are if
they're regular regulatory risk concerns
you might want to go to a degree C just
because it's so widely accepted and so
readily used
hopefully that at least get set some of
the topics around that question thank
you once again dr. passmore I would also
like to thank our sponsor lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through februari 2016 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleague sue me of mr. Danes
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye